I'll see I need you to be my man on the
street knocking on doors interviewing
witnesses cracking skulls kneecapping
pimps what no no no no no no no no no
this is all nonviolent work here look I
know you're the Punisher but for your
new day job why don't you just be Frank
Castle Frank Castle died a long time ago
back in Nam
hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my daredevil episodes one through
three video with Easter eggs so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't
started watching yet if you didn't see
my Jessica Jones videos I'm going to be
doing these just like those so they'll
be like one video for every couple of
episodes the first big arc is
introducing the Frank Castle Punisher
character but he has the most amazing
introduction he is preceded by his
bullets he guns down the Irish and just
like season 1 there are a couple little
stories that end up feeding into a
bigger story so you get to like episode
6 I think I've watched up to about
episode 6 as I'm making this video but
I'm only going to be talking about the
stuff in the first couple episodes so
here we go starting with the luck of the
Irish The Punisher guns down and then
takes the money of one of the Irish
gangs there are three big gangs but they
don't figure out that it's just one
person with military training going
after all of them the intro was a lot of
fun it was a little cheesy on purpose
like you're kind of meant to smirk like
Matt does after he takes down that
villain in the church lot of
heavy-handed religious iconography and
what a coincidence that the Punisher is
Catholic to that first scene with foggy
and matt is just to tell you what's been
going on since season 1 ended and the
series moves in real time so it's been
about a year since they took down Wilson
Fisk
Bogey's joke about waking up with
mystery bruises is a nice allegory for
what Matt does every night the way the
writers describe Matt is that he's like
an alcoholic that goes out every night
just gets wasted just destroys his body
then gets up in the morning feels
terrible but when night comes again he's
ready to go back out and do it again
their intersection with the Punisher
really comes through grotto and I like
the way as mad as investigating we don't
actually see the Punisher for the first
time till he realizes that it's one man
so these really start out as daredevil
versus Punisher and they have a couple
really awesome fights bang what a way to
end that first episode where he shoots
them in the head the way they show you
Matt's perspective like when the sound
cuts out or when they zoom in and focus
on certain things it's a really
interesting storytelling device I think
they make good use of it sometimes
you'll just hear the heartbeat sound
rise up like when he's trying to tell
whether or not grotto is lie to them so
you have this dichotomy between
Daredevil and Punisher and they start
spreading that out to all the other
situations like when Karen Paige is
trying to get files on The Punisher she
goes to the assistant DA
a she presents him with the scenario
where her boss is actually the bad guy
he's trying to do good things they're
trying to do good things it's almost
like everybody on Team daredevil is like
the daredevil character every one of
them foggy Karen and Matt have
situations where they run into punisher
characters where they're confronted with
situations where they play by the rules
they don't play by the rules
like there's even a situation where fog
is like Karen we have to play by the
DA's rules they could crush us and she
wants to go all Punisher and break the
rules so you have like metaphorical
Punishers you have literal Punishers
like the actual Punisher everyone in
Hell's Kitchen is completely divided on
it like they talk about the cops half of
them love what he's doing he makes their
jobs easier the other half thinks he's a
criminal
so it's very similar to what's going on
in season one between Daredevil and
Wilson Fisk
Wilson Fisk also kind of like the
Punisher but we really learned more
about the Punisher once we get to
episodes four through six I'll talk
about that when I get to those videos
but we do actually learn a little bit
about the Punishers backstory he was a
Marine when he's talking to the old guy
there's a nice Easter Egg for the comics
what were you marine yeah I was in
Vietnam in the comics Frank Castle was a
Vietnam vet but because this series is
happening in modern day he's in
Afghanistan vet
Semper Fi marine and I think with that
old Vietnam vet said he was third
division that was also the division the
comic book Frank Castle belonged to so
as he has Matt and chains there and by
the way episode 3 was amazing just
because they kept Matt in Chains for
almost the entire episode till he busts
out and when he does bust out they have
the most epic hallway fight season one
style it's like they take the season one
hallway fight turn it into a stairwell
fight red lights and bam [ __ ] goes down
yeah Punisher gets away but eventually
we learn that the Punisher isn't the
only villain the writers really push the
DEA is the actual villain like the
Punisher is gunning people down yeah
he's doing really bad things but the DEA
is just as evil it's just that it's a
more insidious version of evil she's
kind of like a more twisted version of
the jeryn hogarth character from jessica
jones and there were a couple jessica
jones name drops when foggy goes to see
Claire to see if Matt has been laid up
because he can't find him I got the [ __ ]
Duty because I tried to help one of you
other guys and it went kind of bad she
pissed her bosses off because she cut
out on work to save Luke Cage and they
do address the fact that
even though everybody knows that there
are power people around they dress that
mostly during the Jessica Jones series
they call them enhance people oh you're
one of those there's still a lot of
Secrets oh you think that he left me and
you know she walks away always loved
Claire she's basically letting you know
that she still really likes Matt but
they're not gonna be a thing he's
complicated and I don't need that in my
life Jessica Jones aside she is probably
one of the best Marvel female characters
that they have on screen right now and
she doesn't even have superpowers
the writers even did foggy has solid
this season to season to foggy is much
more sure of himself much more capable
than season one foggy he diffuses all
kinds of bombs like the one in the
hospital in the same thing goes for
Karen Paige she takes this mission to
learn about the Punisher on herself she
goes way above and beyond to try and
help grotto and I think a lot of it has
to do with good old-fashioned Catholic
guilt there's this idea of guilt in the
series father I feel guilty what are you
looking for Matt I'm looking for
forgiveness
for not being able to do enough what the
series is doing is that it's drawing
from all kinds of different comics you
have the daredevil versus Punisher comic
you have the classic daredevil comics
then you have Punisher War Journal
Punisher Max and a little bit of The
Punisher proper series there are a bunch
of different Punisher titles and in them
a lot of his biggest villains come from
regular gangs so like the Irish for
instance in his titles he has fought the
Irish gangs before I actually don't
remember if it's an episode 3 or episode
4 so apologies in advance but we meet
the dog it's named max it debuted during
Punisher the final days that story arc
during the old-school Punisher run like
I said I've seen up to about episode 6
there are a lot more Punisher Easter
eggs for the comics but I'm going to
keep most of that when I do my episode 4
to 6 video so be sure to subscribe to
get that and let me know what is your
favorite thing about the series so far
is that the Punisher character is it
something else I really feel like the
Punisher is the best thing in these
first couple of episodes almost like the
first half of all the episodes are
dedicated to setting up the Frank Castle
character before they try to do more
complex things I really like the way
they're waving the narrative this season
you have all those little tiny cases
that Matt and foggy tried to help people
with they address what happened last
season where they took down Wilson Fisk
they try to make him feel like nobody
cares about that anymore oh yeah you did
that one thing that one time
you're still nobodies we meet the grotto
character
we get introduced to the Punisher and
then it all becomes much much bigger
once we meet the DA she has this grand
plan she wants to be mayor so you can
kind of see the direction they're headed
with that character I'm really
interested in the DA The Punisher is
fascinating but I'm wondering if the DA
is going to wind up the same way the
jeryn hogarth character did so just
careful for spoilers from Jessica John's
unexplained the jeryn hogarth character
she finds herself in a situation where
she can use the killgrave character to
get rid of a problem that she has but it
ends up biting her or stabbing her in
the ass several times she survives
though and starts to serve penance
catholic style I love the way Catholic
guilt spreads across all these Marvel
Netflix series but what's going to
happen is is there's a couple videos
that I have to do between now and Sunday
so my next daredevil video will post on
Monday that'll be episodes 4 through 6
what's going to happen next is is that
there's a whole bunch of Batman V
Superman footage that just drops so I'll
probably do a video for that there's
some Game of Thrones that I'll be doing
tomorrow and then Walking Dead is back
tomorrow night why you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my x-men trailer breakdown and you
can click here for my Captain America
spider-man video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you